the idea that let's say elon musk will
bring back free speech to twitter like
just frame it that way
elon musk is not going to bring back
absolute free speech to twitter that's
not going to happen because you just the
fact that you have to create hierarchies
in the manner in which information is
displayed means that whatever you think
free speech is it can't it can't
completely exist
because you have to prioritize you can't
get the flood of all twitter
at once in your face it's not it's not
it's not possible that that happens so
there has to be a kind of prioritization
and therefore that prioritization is
based on a hierarchy of values and that
hierarchy of values will appear in the
way in which information is displayed to
you
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Music]
because i mean who can possibly well
at this weird time i think it's probably
best in some ways not to think about it
too much in other words i am i'm i'm
[Music]
i am fine
i know what you mean i guess we're fine
as much as as it's possible i try like i
yeah i think like you i've been trying
to
i've actually tried to disconnect a
little bit and try to be focused on
closer things just because it's at some
point it starts ripping you apart and
you uh yeah
there's not much you can do about the
big story you can talk about it a bit
but if you obsess on it too much then
you get
then you can really fall into despair
because there's not much you can do
yeah you can fall in despair and you can
also start you can also start start
thinking of most
ridiculous things because there's so
many people who are trying to find out
exactly what's going on and
how how could you how could you even
know exactly what's going on
yeah because you have a sense that
things are going on
we have the sense that things are
happening and that there's all these you
can see that there's
yeah that there's things happening that
there's directions being taken but it's
all very ambiguous and none of it is is
communicated clearly or it's
communicated through weird secondary
means and stuff so it's
yeah it's hard to really
yeah anyways
yeah and in any case i i think that
insofar as
there are things happening with control
and tech and all the rest of it one of
the great things to do
against that is to do stuff locally and
face to face and person-to-person that's
that is just one of the ways that's one
of the ways of resisting it yeah exactly
yeah creating resilience by having uh
real networks of people that you are
connected to and
that for sure that seems to me
definitely to be the only thing that you
can really do and
but it's hard because at some point at
some point i mean i'm thinking okay i
need to move away from the digital space
just because it's all kind of happening
through the digital space but then
if you do that
i don't know then the digital space also
offers reach which it really does like
it really offers reach and the capacity
to communicate
ideas and so you think if i
if i do that then it also has a cost
which is yes
yeah which is then then your ideas don't
get out there and then you're not part
of the conversation anymore so it's it's
a difficult it's a difficult difficult
decisions to to make
it yeah it's difficult but it in a sense
it's kind of like medicine it's like the
way that medicine is also poison
it's so it's a matter of of using it
wisely i think
rather than you know because you could
you can use technology you can you know
you can you can you can listen to
idiotic tik-tok videos and get into
twitter or you can listen to sort of
documentaries from things you'd never
heard about and talk to people on the
other side of the world
yeah exactly and you can yeah and you
can
and you can network with people in a way
that is not possible in the physical
space it has limited
it's limited and you have to be careful
not to take it for what it's not but it
it's also but it has a certain level of
reality yes um which is which can be
pretty powerful too yes yeah i do think
it needs to be balanced i think it just
needs to be balanced by material reality
as well as just seeing people in person
and i think a lot of people are doing
that actually i think a lot of people
are more doing crafts uh you know
learning woodwork just
just
it just gets fed up with living totally
in mangled heads
yeah definitely definitely so i think
that what i wanted i really enjoyed you
sent me a message about agency
and i think that it would be really
interesting to go into that in terms of
you know my discussion with with john
ravaki and also the question of how
beings stack up and how they exist at
different levels um and so maybe you can
if you want you could give a sense of
what you were talking about in terms of
agency and we could start from there i
think that'd be really interesting all
right okay i have to try and remember
now i'll have to remember because i
thought we're going to be talking about
digital id well let's talk about digital
id and defend if you think we if you
would you is that what you rather talk
about would you rather whatever i just
have to try and remember what i said
about
okay so then we can talk about digital
id then that's totally fine that's
totally fine we could talk about the
agency as well because i could just
i could just kind of try and find it
can i just read quickly skim through you
mentioned that agency that even higher
level agency doesn't necessarily require
uh consciousness and that to a certain
extent consciousness
is
that that most of the things we do with
agency
actually require don't require
consciousness to kind of seep into the
things you're doing so right you're
going downstairs skills as you master
skill you actually become less and less
conscious of that skill
yes and so i really thought that was a
really great point because it can also
help us understand the fall and the
relationship of like the notion that
knowledge of the specifics
isn't necessarily always uh it's not
necessarily a good it can actually be a
danger because you're actually falling
into the into the lower tiers whereas as
you as you um
let's say as you join them together
you're you can be moving up in the world
and you become less you can become
something like super conscious so there
could be there's a sense in which there
is a super consciousness
uh which is not the same as unconscious
in the sense of of ignorance and
and just not knowing what you're doing
because that's also re that also exists
like let's say the state before you
learn a skill yes you're not aware of it
and you you can't discern you can't
discern difference you can't you can't
know what's relevant and what's
irrelevant and then you learn the skill
and then you reach a point where those
points kind of fuse together into a
state of super consciousness where you
actually now are not are no longer
conscious of the distinctions you just
engage with them uh and so i think that
that's a really interesting idea
yeah so yeah that's that's what i was
thinking about because in terms of
in terms of what you're talking about
with john
you came across a point where you were
worried about the notion of moral
responsibility that could you be
responsible for something if you weren't
if you weren't conscious of it but but
of course you can be in fact in fact
when we praise it it's easier to see it
in terms of when we pray somebody for
their skill
you know a concert pianist isn't going
to be thinking you know consciously
remembering
the scales and where to put each finger
you would just would be unable to do it
and i presume like when you're doing
your carving
your
the stuff that you had to learn that you
would you know you just do it
automatically i should imagine
yeah and there's something there's a
sense in which like you can see that in
the positive where you accumulate a
skill
and then you become unconscious of it
but you could also see it as a habit
sometimes like like a bad habit that at
first you engage with consciously and
then slowly it becomes part of your
being
and then you know you
you're not let's say you're not
conscious of the nastiness you're
spreading sometimes yeah you're actually
unconscious of it because it's been
completely
assimilated to your being
yes so when you then the judgment of
whether or not you know whether or not
you're responsible for that it's going
to depend upon
so so much so much else how you got
there
uh
how how you developed it how you fell
into it and what the consciousness what
self-consciousness you had
as you were going what you were actually
trying to aim towards so if you're
you're actually aiming towards for good
then you would incorporate things but if
you're developing those bad habits that
assumingly you weren't aiming towards
you wouldn't because
but it's interesting because one of the
things that we've seen like in terms of
narrative
in the past few generations
is the idea that all the bad stuff that
you have as a result of you know let's
say your parents like your parents were
a certain way
and then you've accumulated these these
patterns and now you're repeating the
pattern so it's like my mother's fault
you know i'm a yes you know i'm mean to
my kids and it's my mother's my parents
fault basically yes yeah yeah but do you
know that philip larkin poem
no
oh right it's it's you know philip
larkin is this uh like really famous
20th century british poet who always
said the most miserable pose and the
poem the poem actually contains
an anglo-saxon word but it's like they
they f you up your mum and dad they may
not mean to but they do they fill you
with the faults they had and add a few
more just for you
and so it's it's that kind of idea
yeah and so you can really see how
the problem of the problem of agency is
there even in the question like our
modern pop psychology and the way we
we kind of understand ourselves we have
a sense in which we can actually do bad
things and not be
responsible and say it's my parents
fault basically
yes
and so how do we then
how do we how do you see the question of
consciousness in terms of
or how do you see the relationship of
agencies at different levels like have
you thought about that in terms of the
notion of personal agency but then
there's a sub-personal agency and then
transpersonal agency in terms of
of larger beings like teams or families
or sports or you know or nations
well yeah
i mean that's a really interesting
question but
you you'd have to you in order for it to
work as a team you'd have to have some
kind of
you know some kind of shared goal
wouldn't you and some awareness of where
you were in the team but that can
actually that can actually happen it can
actually happen through
um
so through training and through
deliberately doing stuff like in it like
in a for example in an orchestra in an
orchestra you're you're aiming to
or or in a choir in a choir you could
sing as a soloist but if you're singing
in a choir your aim is to blend in with
a choir your aim is not to sort of stand
out a little of a soloist if you're and
if you're playing in an orchestra your
aim is to make your sound
you know um so if you're playing second
flute in the flute section your aim is
to make your sound blend in with the
with the first flute and
all the rest of the orchestra so you'd
it that would have to be done that's a
huge amount of skill would have to be it
would have to be aimed towards a you
know a goal that you're all trying to
that you're all trying to achieve but it
can it can actually happen kind of
spontaneously can i tell you can i tell
you a story yeah sure about a time when
i um
caught a thief in amsterdam
like it was actually it was absolutely
this was absolutely fantastic it was
like i've got a friend who lives in
amsterdam and i've gone to visit her for
the weekend and we'd like gone out we'd
gone out on the town various places
which i hadn't done for such a long time
because i've been at home with kids so
yeah you'd kind of forget where you were
and we were walking along in the middle
of amsterdam and there's a group of
young men just overtook us
and as they overtook us one of them just
turned around and glanced back at me and
i knew instantly like he gave me the
evil eye basically i knew instantly he's
he's got my purse
i just knew it before we'd even i'd even
checked in my pocket he snatched my
burst and my friend and i were
we had been cycling so we were wheeling
on reeling bikes along and we just acted
as if we'd been training for years so we
just scooted on our bikes she went ahead
she went ahead of him and caught her
because he was on foot and caught him
like that and i went behind like that
and we trapped him against the wall with
our bikes
and he was he was absolutely petrified
and threw my purse away and ran off um
but it was it was it was it was fanta it
was a really fantastic example of we
hadn't planned this at all we just
we just somehow we was
actually together yeah
and it's interesting because you can
understand like anybody who's played a
sport and is good at playing team sports
or has done something or or uh like they
made a
worked in a play or something where all
of a sudden everybody you actually give
up
your immediate agency to a certain
extent or like your independent agency
in order to
participate in a higher form of agency
there's a weird kind of magic that
happens and you can you can even
experience it almost like as a as a form
of ecstasy you it's like a little
ecstasy
because you feel as if you are you're
participating in something bigger than
you it's like you know when that feeling
of playing i don't you're playing
basketball with someone you're used to
playing with and you don't even think
about it you're not looking you make the
pass you know they're there you don't
know why you know they're there and then
they get it and it's like and you have
the sense of like uh right the world is
won or whatever it's almost like a
little religious experience to have that
to have that happen to you yes but i
don't i don't think that means that the
team itself is conscious i don't think
it means that there's a kind of
subjective awareness for team itself in
the same sort of way as
as you know different parts of you don't
need to have
you know in the same way in which you're
learning a skill that doesn't have to be
consciousness
you can have consciousness in the sense
of having knowledge of what's going on
but that's different from a sense of
like a subjective awareness of what's
actually happening so i don't think the
team needs to have that
back subjective awareness
exactly so the question would be like
so this i mean this is what i've been
thinking about like this is the question
that i have and so one of the things
that i've been thinking about is how
organizations like teams and and those
types of organizations organize
themselves hierarchically and there's
usually
there's often a point you know like a
team captain or a coach or maybe there's
a few but there's a sense in which they
can maybe become the locus of
consciousness of the of the team and so
it's so the team does have a form of
agency and consciousness but it's
expressed in the hierarchy
through people right and so that's why
you have a leader and so the leader is
actually the locus of
consciousness for the for the group but
it's a so so in a sense
the the
so that's why i would think that the
group probably does have a form of
consciousness and agency but it needs to
be it needs to happen in that way it's
not just automatic it has to happen in a
way in which there's a point
like a leader that is directing action
and is also a reference point that we
all agree on in order in order for what
we're doing and so in that way we can
have
but like in your case that's not what
happened so for example like you said
all of a sudden
two people are acting in unison towards
a goal and so and there's no there's no
like there's no person there's just a
reason the reason is what is making that
body exist at that moment yes but i
imagine in that kind of case because my
friend our friend and i both had we
would have had a lifetime of common
experiences of maybe she's
a person
and we're both women who who
who have the experience of if you're if
you're a woman you have a different
sense of safety in the street with your
man you know on average so but we would
have had those
and also she's like she i mean she her
fam i was originally friends with her
mother i mean the most kind of like
determined amazing family so it's also
it's also her personality but it's it
can just happen spontaneously like that
but also it can go wrong so um in terms
of a team so i i um i actually have just
been watching um
there's a netflix documentary about this
space shuttle challenger disaster
which is just like a horrible example
of that not happening because there were
so many different goals but for
management we're after so
there was pressure on nasa so that was a
disaster where if you remember it was in
1986 1987 i think that was supposed to
be the first teacher in space
so it's the first time they had a sort
of like the civilian going up in space
and one of the reasons why they did that
was because people were losing interest
in the space shuttle so they needed to
have public interest to get
um
you know
to get the funding continued
and there was there they were the launch
had been failed you know belong to being
delayed because of various reasons and
there were all so many people in the
organization warning
warning people in the management but the
o-rings were going to fail
there was ice on that there was ice on
the shuttle when they launched it
and there's different different strands
in management as to what their goals
were
yeah so you can see how the the let's
say the goal was not a good that could
bind that together like let's say the
goal of getting good marketing a good pr
uh impression let's say that's not the
type of goal that can bind a space
shuttle uh team in order to succeed so
if it had been if it is bound by a
better
by a better good
then then all those things would not
have happened like they wouldn't they
would not have
happened that way yeah i mean i mean
there's another element of that is the
element of spec element of spectacle but
also because of because for children
involved it's in a sense it's reverse of
what should have happened because
because there were children watching
like there were millions of american
school children watching yeah
launched her school her pupils at the
launch
and and her children she had never
school teachers obviously all the
astronauts had had families but
they wouldn't have had millions of
children watching so you would have
thought they should have had
higher standards of safety but it led to
having lower standards like distracted
like oh it's for the kiddies the kitties
will find it fun
but that's that's
i've noticed that kind of thing happens
happens a lot actually in terms of
luring us to do things it's a bit sort
of
you know a bit it's a real distraction
actually yeah and there's also like we
talk about how it can go wrong there's
also ways it can go wrong when it can go
too well
right where this is of course the cult
or the
you know or the the let's say the the
tyrannical the possibility of a
tyrannical leader that sucks up the
people so much into
a higher cause that they cease to almost
exist as individuals and they just
become
they just become nodes for this this
pattern and so then it can spiral
because it
you know because there is like a real
ecstasy in participating in something
bigger than you like that's a real thing
and so you can weaponize that
uh
towards towards bad
towards evils if you fewer if you're
capable like if you're a charming cult
leader you can drag people in and make
them really feel that sense and it's
it's real it's not an illusion it's it's
really happening but then they then they
can lead to uh there's a there's a movie
a crazy horror movie what it's called
mid-summer that a-24 put out uh like a
few years ago where they explore the
problem of a
basically a cult that
that they the individuals almost cease
to exist like they have someone gets
hurt everybody feels it like there's a
sympathy all through yeah and then it
draws them in so much but then there's
also obviously like this it's crazy dark
side to it which is that you know they
end up killing all these strangers and
they have to part they have to do these
these these types of uh of murders in
order to cohere their group together um
but you can see like in in any we can
see it from in hindsight when we look at
movements like mouse uh mao's cultural
revolution for example
yeah i don't think i think that could be
happening at the same time within an
organization so that kind of that kind
of thing could have been happening
i'd say within within nasa with people
who've identified so much of the
organization
so one of the things i find really
worrying about a lot of the big tech
giants like places like google and so on
when they just people are just
they're like nurtured like babies like
they
their whole lives are on site
everything's laid onto them
um so that you you you're you can really
get some under one of one of the main
findings that social psychologists who
look at the ways in which people can
make disastrously wrong decisions or
things can look evil can come out of
good intention is that you should make
certain you've got more than one social
reference group
but so that if you know if you go to
work but you also belong to a church or
you could even like a bridge club or
anything differently no you're right i
this is something that i've been talking
about recently too which is that
the the buffer against this type of
excess is a fractal identity system so
the idea is that a real
healthy traditional society would have a
fractal
levels of identity where like you said
you you have your family you have clubs
you have different clubs that are based
on different things you can maybe have a
sports club or uh something that
celebrates some aspect of your even if
it is your nation or whatever but you
know you have the what is it in quebec
they had like the daughters of isabel
and the knights of columbus but then
they also had you know the
so you had all these different like
organizations and they would scale up
in a way that that was fractal so
the nation doesn't compete with these
lower levels they just exist at lower
levels and they actually build on each
other in order to succeed but what you
can see in the kind of tyrannical single
identity
problem
is how it wants to actually eliminate
the intermediary
uh let's say uh allegiances and mao's
cultural revolution is actually a great
example of that where mao actually tried
to eliminate all intermediary
allegiances you know to as superstitious
in order to bind everybody to one
central one which was the state yeah so
what one of the things you need for that
is actually um a block on communication
and on knowledge so for example you
might get like a woman's group within a
church and what happens is that they'll
be moaning about how stupid they think
the sermon was this week for example
oh you know what
that actually that kind of thing is
is necessary but there's there's there's
a block on community a block on
communication so but you can you can get
together and say what you really think
about things or talk about things more
privately but i think that's one of the
big one of the big problems with
one of the big problems with the kind of
thinking behind a lot of the digital
stuff now it's like an ethos but data is
good information is good and then
straight away equating that with
communication
with open communication but i think that
but actually what works what works then
um
different pathways of knowledge of
information and
does that make sense in terms of
oh definitely i totally agree uh and i'm
trying to see like i'm trying to
one of the things it seems like so so
when you have a fractal system of of
identities there's a there's certain
constraints on that fractal system which
are just just the fact that you live in
a village you have people around you
like maybe you have a club that's
actually bigger than your village but
you can't meet all the time so maybe i
don't know like you're in a guild of
whatever you're guild of people making
jewelry so a few once every few years
you can get together with your guild and
so there's all these limiting factors
which create
which actually bind the hierarchy in a
normal way so you spend a lot of time
with your family so you have that
private space in order to air out like
you can like you said you can complain
to your husband or to your wife about
how bad the sermon was or whatever so
you can kind of have these these fractal
structures one of the things that the
online space does is that because it's
the potentiality is
is unbound you could say and so so right
so on
let's say in in a normal
like in a normal traditional world you
might have someone with kooky ideas in
the village and that person they'll be
kooky they'll have weird ideas they'll
be they'll be strange it might be a bit
obsessive and so you keep an eye on them
you watch them you're careful they don't
spend too much time with your kids or
whatever so there's like a natural like
system but what happens online is that
that kooky person with like really crazy
kooky ideas can now be connected to 10
000 other people all around the world
that have those crazy kooky ideas so
because of that then
from those that hold the reins of power
they suddenly feel the need to
i'm trying to play devil's advocate here
they they they feel the need to want to
stifle that because they can see
let's say a pattern which would exist in
the in the world regularly but would be
constrained is now more and more
unconstrained because of that what tech
offers
so they have to bring down on it more
control than what you would in a in a
village situation
yes i think that's what's happening
because a lot of the stuff that's
happening is
a solution is brought in by technology
to solve the problems that technology
has created the technology freeze itself
yeah and also what happens
what generally tends to happen so
technology
creates problems
ben
rides to the rescue like you know the
guys for white hats on are rescuing it
they cause a problem in the first place
and it's always the individual people
who get blamed so that you know the
technology is designed in ways that
would enable that kind of thing and then
the people who are behaving like this
seem to be like
dreadful people well they might they
might not be all that great as people
but
it's the technology that's enabled them
to do it but
but it also i mean it just happens
this can happen anyway
in in ways in which society is becoming
um more more fractured you know like
people who live in suburbs are very
distanced and in lots of cities it's
actually also becoming fractured because
there are different populations
in different demographics and different
population groups i'm living kind of
like almost sort of separate parallel
lives
um but there's i don't know
i was thinking about this last week just
for again something personal that i
noticed which is that i live in a my
property's leasehold which because i own
it but it's on land owned by the council
they want to change the lease and they
want to introduce a clause whereby which
is a harassment clause but you're not
supposed to use an abusive or offensive
language um
for race sex culture or other
characteristic
and the kind of thing this is the kind
of thing which is happening in the
digital space and it's happening here as
well so how much is how much are people
thinking
how much people kind of learning from a
kind of control in the digital space and
thinking we have to have it in the real
world
no that's a really good point because
there's a there's a sense in which
how can i say this this is gonna this is
gonna sound
people are gonna find this really weird
but there's a sense in which
the let's say like abusive
language for example or you're using
kind of horrible language those are
things that happen in the world like
they happen and the thing is that
doing that in the world
can bring you can let's say
can create certain situations like you
can actually impose your strength on on
others if you use those types of
language but it actually also creates
problems for you it actually has a cost
and that cost plays itself out in the
world especially in a world that has
more and more uh let's say
different groups interacting with each
other and so it's like you know that
racist uncle it's like oh yeah i have
that racist uncle so that racist uncle
you know you're annoyed with him he's
annoying you just kind of you but you
still meet with him you know for
thanksgiving or whatever but it's like
he's just annoying but because of
because of you're right it's interesting
because of the online space it's so
pervasive and then you see these mobs
and these patterns that appear then all
of a sudden it's like oh that racist
uncle who's annoying and and and
offensive it's like i want him to get
fined i want him to go to jail because i
can see it as part of this larger kind
of pattern that's happening in in the
digital space
yeah because i mean that has been
happening in how people have been
divided in things like whether you're
vaccinated or not and
it's i mean people are
i mean here it's different in different
countries because in here in britain
it just seems to have stopped it's like
it's mostly over and if you tiptoe
around you can just avoid having rounds
with people it's just like it vanished
into thin air
um
it's different in different places but
it could it could get ri it could get
really unpleasant
it could be yeah it's like this is a
moment where i wish the queen would
would remind the canada that we're in
the commonwealth and that you know
but now that's not what's going on here
in canada it's like my goodness
this has to stop but it's not going to
stop it's really been weaponized that he
where we are and and it's been
politicized all of this whole question
is
is really becoming a political tool and
and if you can actually see it play out
and you can realize that right now those
in power in canada have absolutely no
reason
to back down they have they have every
reason to hold on to this because it's
to their political advantage in every
way and so
it's a yeah it's a it's a bit of a it's
a bit of a strange time
yeah
can't be queen just sacked trudeau can't
you do that
in theory she can through the the the
in theory she can but it's never gonna
happen that's never gonna happen
no it's never gonna happen yeah no it's
never gonna happen yeah so i think i'd
like to it's funny because i didn't
think when i thought we're going to talk
about agency and then you thought we're
going to talk about digital id but it's
just super interesting that those have
even in our own conversation they kind
of come together
so there's a sense in which
because of the digital space because of
the digital space itself and what it
offers and also the dangers of it it
seems as if
the
the need for a single id like of a
single identification that will
encompass all of your being
it seems to be pressing upon us as
something which
is inevitable
uh and so we can like i i hate
everything about it but i also see
that i can also see that because of what
the because i participate in the digital
sphere i can notice that without that
at some point it becomes untenable like
the digital space becomes antenna but
without something like that so what are
your thoughts about these because we
have one in quebec right now where we
are it's happening right now in june the
digital id project is starting in
ontario in another province it's already
already started um and so we are seen as
the
we are seen as the forerunners right
there's a video of our of our banking
association and it's like the president
of the banking association whatever
canadian banking association for the
world economic forum saying like canada
is going to be is going to spearhead
this the single digital identity thing
and it's related to to banking of course
because it's related to security and to
the problem that that online banking
poses because of identification and
security
yeah so so is it going to be just used
for banking or is it going to be just
yeah it's going to be used for
everything
and it's going to be compulsory
well no that well of course it's going
to be compulsory but not right away
right away it's all voluntary
and so it's all voluntary but like
there's a
it's it's voluntary but it's biometric
it's in in terms of quebec they've been
they've said clearly that there's going
to be a biometric element to the digital
id so you can you can see that if
so there's this is
i don't know if this is the case but i
find it very interesting to notice that
both
both our prime minister and my premier
in quebec
they although they're not using like
here in quebec they're not using the the
vaccine passport anymore but they they
said don't remove it from your phone
right because we might need it later
right
and so you realize that with a biometric
id
then all of this can will can easily
become compulsory like it it
any other any other pandemic any other
disease or anything and all of a sudden
it all becomes compulsory because it's
like a perfect it's a perfect storm
where you need to control people at the
entry in stores you need a digital id
they scan your face or your eyes when
you walk in they let you in if you're
vaccinated or not and then you just pick
things up you walk out of the store and
you paid everything it's like it's
perfect it's it's it's but you can see
how will easily become compulsory with
with with the with the kobit or another
pandemic question
yeah i mean it could it could easily
become it could easily become compulsory
but i mean we get um we can easily get
sucked into this sort of piece by piece
again again one of the things about
agency there in terms of the attraction
the attraction of having a digital id
it's being pushed forward in some
circles as being it makes life so much
easier online because you just have one
you wouldn't have to have all your
different passwords
um
it would be just so it's
presented to us as actually enhancing
your agency
of course
which it actually does of course it does
for reverse it's enhanced your agency to
engage with technology so the
technologies the technology produces a
world which in some ways obviously
enables you to do lots of things but on
the other hand you have to do it in the
way that
technology sets out exactly and it also
as it becomes centralized then you're
also giving up all your agency into that
centralized system and so
if if let's say
50 years ago
it was really hard to turn a citizen off
because
their birth certificate was a piece of
paper their you know their their their
cards were all you know they had money
in their bank account they had money
it's like it was all decentralized and
so it was really hard to turn someone
off as you create a centralized system
then all this comes together and it then
it ends up centralizing into a a
government digital id
then
it's like click
yes of course the whole system's much
more fragile both in a piece of paper
because the whole thing could just
the whole thing could just the whole
thing could just disappear the whole
thing yeah that's the tower of babel
like that's the problem of too big to
fail too which is that as you kind of
give up your
your all of this kind of gets
centralized into one space then it yeah
actually
yeah but but also in many ways they
oversell it to themselves so for example
when that about vaccine passports say it
has to be digital it didn't have to be
digital actually because you could have
had you could have had a stamp in your
passport you could just have to in the
old days you just had a vaccination
little card so it doesn't have to be
digital so so again a lot of it is just
a lot of it is over selling stuff in
order to justify its own existence
but that happened the time but but it
but it's also it's like it's interesting
because there's also technology offers
it offers something and so for example
like
if you have a centralized id system like
a server like we add here like yes you
have a centralized system of cobit
passports then the state is regulating
it and the state is is matt
is controlling it it's like if you have
a card with like a
w with the date of your vaccine and the
doctor's signature yeah it's like that
could be faked very easily right it
could be easily faked and so and so
there's the sensor because because
technology offers us the capacity
because one of the problems that happens
is
as soon as there's control there's
corruption right there's no corruption
if there's no control there's no need
for corruption there's no control
control systems bring about corruption
and then the control system wants to
cover for that corruption through more
control and so technology offers an
unlimited version of that
yes like indefinite scaling of what that
that that brings about yeah because it's
good because it's going to go it's going
to
it's going to be
claimed to be uncorruptable somebody
will manage to hack it but it's it's
like when you you develop locks so you
have to become you have just become one
step ahead of
the people who can crack locks it's it's
that's that's that's what's going to be
that's what's going to be happening um
and you can feel it like it's funny
because i can i can i don't i don't know
how to say this like you can feel it for
example two-step identification has
become
mandatory it's almost everywhere now you
can almost can't get out of it my my
banking app asked me a few weeks ago if
i wanted to use facial recognition to
get onto the to the banking app and i
was like okay well i guess i mean i knew
we were there but it's like it's just
weird to have the app tell you well you
know it's
it and almost hinting at you know you
can put it off for a little while
but you might yeah you might be able to
put it off forever soon you're gonna
have to or else you're not gonna have
access to the service anymore
yes
but of course
i suppose
i suppose for back
one of the things that struck me i mean
for banking i suppose it's it's
it's to do with the security of your of
your money yeah
but of course one of the reasons why
your money is so insecure is because of
the digital digital i i actually every
time i log into my account i have this
free sort of fear but what it's
completely empty that you're gonna get
it's just gonna be zero yeah i know what
you mean because it's like it's not
you know if i there's a way in which uh
let's say
you know my money if i have it under my
bed it's locally insecure yeah yeah like
it but but i know like it's there i know
it's like if someone breaks in or
whatever but this this the this is
virtual world yes yes
yeah the whole the whole system is set
up to increase anxiety so even so even
so even some of the
some of the advan advantages of having a
one digital id because then you don't
need to remember all the passwords it's
because i mean i wrote down i recently
wrote all my passwords down in the book
because there are so many of them there
were like 300 i had 300 different
passwords and but some of them they have
they have ludicrously high standards for
what you have for something like who who
is going to sign into some obscure
academic journal and write a review on
my behalf nobody's going to do it but
not but so so they're inventing
ludicrous levels of security so there's
like this constant state of anxiety that
we're living in it's really heightened
state of and and because it's all bitter
you you could just forget your passwords
you could just
um i suppose if it's
it's it's it's interesting that they're
introducing the digital i'm in the um
biometric firm for banking because one
of the things that's one of the things
that i was thinking about because we
you probably have it somewhere here but
i'm not sure the ways of the first
things that they introduced
biometrics in was the things where the
state was interested in security so
passport control
and
and police things yeah and banking it
was just it was more like you
remembering the information it's one of
the things i'm really interested in
in thinking about are a ways in which
digital id is controlled in terms of the
levels of information and then also for
material realization
because
so say say take vaccine passports for
example um if you think if the state say
you have to have vaccine passports you
think they would provide you with so
when you had a vaccine certificate in
the old days when you just got
vaccinated you got a bit of paper
paper now you have to buy the phone
yourself
you are paying for the phone and you're
paying for the data each month in order
for the state to control you
it seems like
it seems like a bit of a con
yeah and
and also but in terms of
digital identity i was thinking about
that a lot because the word identity is
carrying so much work yeah so it's
identity in terms of individuating you
as a person which you can do like you
say jonathan pejo
the canadian icon carver you know
there's only is there any one russian
russian orthodox right
i'm just joking because that's what
jordan peterson called the russian
orthodox i don't know
didn't you say you were a former
catholic atheist yeah yeah that was
hilarious i like it was just funny i
love jordan it was funny actually
that's an interesting example because it
still identifies you you still everybody
still knew who he meant yeah exactly
yeah
um but but
but there's something about the the
question of identity is is super
important like i mean i guess that's the
question of the day it's a question of
of our time you know the problem of
identity and the problem of identities
in general and how how these work and
and the excesses that our world has
brought about which is on the one hand
this fluidity of identity this notion
that identities are fluid that we praise
hybrid identities that we have all of
these
but there's also a desire to totally map
out and control identity at the same
time those two extremes are happening at
the same time and the idea for example
so you would understand like in a
traditional way or like i think in a
mystical christian way you would
understand something like
you would have the notion that identity
is apophatic
that to a certain extent identity leads
to mystery and so behind identity is
something like a mystery there's
something you know it's like christ in
you you could say it that way or you
could say the divine light the divine
spark there's something behind you
behind all your named identities which
is
which is which is higher and is can be
completely contained and that is
actually it's all that's a really
important part of what identity is and
what it leads to but there's a sense in
which
the idea of digital identity and the
idea that you could
have a name or a number or something
which identifies you without which
you
cease to exist
almost in practice like or that you
cease to exist socially at least like
you couldn't exist
socially you can't it's already there
like you know social security numbers
and all these types of of identification
it's not like this is one thing that's
happening now it's something that's been
building up for
you know for a century or more um but
the idea that if you don't have this
then you don't exist for socially i mean
that's a
crazy idea
well yeah i mean because there are
people who live like that but
one of the things that fascinates me is
how identity can mean just like picking
out one individual person so that's it's
just about a matter of separating one
person from another which of course but
of course in a sense the state has to do
that in terms of like tax
which is legitimate and so on and
but but also identity so that's just
simply bear you know bare identification
of one individual as opposed to another
individual but then we use identity to
mean
um you know our essence or how we're
going to make ourselves or our agency or
what makes us really just really
distinctive of filling out the
filling out the individual things and
that's one of the things i was thinking
about in thinking about how like you
know vaccine passports and all the rest
of it are actually physically on your
phone on a person's phone
because if you have a if you have a
smartphone which most people do now then
it's also the smartphone is also where
you are you know looking at videos
engaging with friends get getting
getting lots of feedback interacting in
the world in a way which is building up
your your identity in the online space
connecting to friends but it's also
where which is so that's quite that's
too too sort of
you know slightly
um
you know not quite the same thing but
all
actually physically embodied in the same
device that you that you're carrying
around with you yeah
it's collecting information about you
collecting information about you all the
time
so there's also the notion of a digital
identity in terms of the identity that's
being constructed out of the vast trail
of information that we're leaving where
wherever we go
yeah the digital twin
and yeah and
there's a sense in which you get it you
get an idea that it's
that the moving toward digital identity
and even biometric measure especially
is moving towards a space where your
digital twin it's like in a movie right
your digital twin replaces you yes and
becomes the truer self yes because it's
actually the self by which all your
social interactions and social
uh clout all your participation in
reality that's the one that is
measured like that's one that's
measuring all those things yes yeah i
mean it
could go into directions from here now
but yeah you know there are some people
who are trying to do that trying to
actually make digital twins like trying
to create so martin rothblatt is trying
to make
um
a
uh scottish robot being a 64 i think
it's called it's trying to make an
identical copy
of of um
i forget if
martin i forget whether martin rothbach
is a man or a woman because it's one of
these people who transitioned but
or her wife tried to make an identity
and and you get the idea that ray
kurzweil and people like that have of
trying to actually upload ourselves
completely get a copy of our mind and
upload ourselves but yeah into the into
the into the but these are narrative
like it's important i think it's
important to understand these types of
events let's say someone who's doing
that as a narrative crux like as a
narrative point it makes you notice a
pattern that's happening more generally
that is they are you are building your
digital twin you're doing it all the
time we're do we are building a kind of
digital twin uh and that then you have
examples where this becomes almost like
uh like a mythical ritualized version of
it where someone is like building a
robot and like you know like training it
to be them uh and so we find that odd
but it's important to understand it
rather as a marker to understand
something that's happening on a bigger
on a bigger scale which is this is
this is being done to you like we are
building our digital twins
yeah and so so a lot of our problems i
think would arise when you actually
start believing that all this data about
you is actually you so i think that gets
back to what you're talking about a
christian sense of of you know the self
being that the identity being being a
mystery
because because it has a causal it's
super important what you're saying is
super important because it has a causal
effect on you you can imagine that this
causality can be reversed and you can
see little examples of that imagine like
a little example of that that you can
find is like the you see it in
celebrities sometimes where a celebrity
develops an uh persona
and then that persona invades them yeah
and then they become a caricature of
themselves and they become like you know
they become a caricature of their own
persona uh and so you can see that
happening in the in in the world it's
the kind of thing that's already already
exist but in the digital space it's a
it's far more
it's dangerous and it's dangerous on the
scale that's everybody like everybody
can can be colonized by their facebook
instagram
uh persona and the algorithm is doing
that to you too because if you if you go
and you visit certain sites then the
advertisements start to reflect that
digital twin and then that's not as if
it's not as if it's neutral that
return is actually going to
affect you and is going to causally
transform you in a way that
that will make you more of the into that
twin like even you as a as a in your
full in the fullness of yourself will
make you more into that twin yeah i
think one i think one of the ways in
which that's happening is in in terms of
the ways in which
a conflation between information or data
and actually knowledge and understanding
so
data that's the data that's collected is
just like little little points of
information which have been analyzed in
various ways and you can you know
connect you can extract meaning out of
it or you can extract sometimes pseudo
meaning because what's what drops out of
the data it hasn't got any meaning at
all it's just like
say some piece of machine learning is is
is putting stuff together in a way
that's sort of nonsensical but that's
not how we understand ourselves um
there's a
there's a there's a really interesting
um
there's some interesting work from uh
somebody called neil lawrence who's
professor of machine learning at
cambridge and he mostly works
technically in machine learning he's got
some really interesting stuff about the
difference between how minds work and
how artificial intelligence or machines
work he's actually got a really good ted
talk on it but he's written some stuff
on it as well so he talks about what he
calls the embodiment factor which is in
it just to just to cut a lot of it
really quickly one of the main
differences between how computers
proceed information and how we do is
that he says we all have what he calls
locked in syndrome so compared to
computers we are more like um he uses
the example of jean paul boby who was um
he's written a book for diving
benevolent and a butterfly it's a
brutally actually a really beautiful
book actually he he had a catastrophic
stroke and ended up and
communicated through blinking his eye
and um he said that human beings are all
more like him when we are like computers
because how we communicate
um in terms of our brains of processing
absolutely
massive amounts of information all the
time if you had to think about what you
can see right now
and communicate to somebody else exactly
everything that you could even just see
right now you couldn't do it so if
somebody's worked out in terms of
information theory it would take you
something like
longer than the age of a universe to be
able to just
communicate what you're seeing yeah
what's in just that just the complexity
of the world that's presenting itself to
you and computers are computational way
around they can communicate really
really quickly so i mean what we need to
be doing is using them in complement
complementary ways but the result of
that for how we think is that we have to
communicate uh so for example from
poetry through art but also because we
have access to our own indus
understanding we can know immediately so
for example when um my friend and i were
both chasing that thief in amsterdam
we both had immediate access to like a
whole store of similar maybe similar
things that have happened maybe we've
watched the same police films
you know we've got we could instantly
know she's i can tell from what she's
doing but what she's going to do she's
yeah he's trying to catch him
as well so yeah
so the way which we communicate is we
can you know communicate through poetry
and so on um so
so
i thought that might be interesting just
to and i would really recommend his ted
talk actually i think it's um it's
really interesting because he's
it's interesting as well because a lot
of the people who actually work really
intensely in tech
exactly but people who who are skeptical
about whether or not
artificial intelligence is at all like
human intelligence yeah
very
very very different
but
this roundabout way of saying yes but
emphasizing the dangers of thinking that
the digital information collected about
you is actually anything like what you
are like because it's missing so much
it's missing so much stuff and it's
interpreting the data in a way it's sort
of like machine readable but anybody
else can access it but we access
ourselves
quite differently and information means
and what's information to one person
is something completely different
completely different it means something
yeah
so
i mean another example
but that's might be easy to grasp to
illustrate all this
um i've recently been looking at um i
think i mentioned before i do some work
the team of people who do research on
the care of patients with dementia
mm-hmm i've been looking there's lots of
there's lots of research trying to
um trying to
find ways of using using machine
learning to help diagnose dementia and
it's interesting that they want to try
to diagnose dementia earlier so some
there are some teams trying to diagnose
dementia like decades before the first
symptoms
which is really really interesting
because if you haven't got any symptoms
what does that mean to say you have
dementia
um so they're trying to do it from
really my new little
ways in which your brain
works or how
in all the
suggestions that you collect all the
information from all your health
information from every health
insurance you ever had information from
things like your gate how you use
computers how you use
um if you're
connected up to the internet of things
how you use technology around you
all sorts of data um and then try to
claim you can build up a picture this is
a picture of um that you have that you
now have dementia or diagnosed with
dementia and just assuming this is a
good thing
but they haven't actually thought that
for them this might be interesting
information for research but for a
person to be told bad
or to be told but actually you may be
functioning perfectly well in everyday
life but we can tell from how you've
answered this little puzzle but you've
got the beginnings of your brain isn't
processing information quite the normal
way and actually this means
they haven't
not necessarily thinking that this is
going to mean something medical
information means something to an
individual
you're not a neutral agent that'll just
receive it won't it'll have a causal
effect on you yeah yeah so how can you
do something about it like you can do
something about it if you knew that
information would be horrible
yeah it would be horrible wouldn't it it
would be horrible it's it's actually uh
sorry this is this is this is going off
off topic a bit if it's a real example
about how tech sells itself because they
start off by saying we have to do this
because i mentioned such a terrible
terrible disease in a way that nobody
working in dementia care would would go
on about how awful it was because people
have to live with it so you're trying to
make it as livable as as possible and
then half the papers say we need to
diagnose dementia as early as possible
so that we can
have treatment again treatment and the
other half say we need to die those as
early as possible because there is no
treatment
so can you imagine but that's a great
this is a super great example to
understand the problem of the digital
twin or like the information twin or
even like the
so so think about it like uh you can
give yourself a like a speculative
example like you you could diagnose
dementia in a person 10 years old right
so you have a 10 year old kid and you
diagnose that when they are 75
they will have dementia and so you tell
them like okay so now we know that
you're gonna have dementia when you're
75
and so if you do like an hour of this
exercise or you take this drug every day
for the rest of your life then then you
then there's a 70 chance that when
you're 75 right you won't have dementia
so you can see like so that means that
you're going to make that person's
entire life managed by this thing
and and and it's going to it's going to
basically take up their all their
resources and and it'll be like
it's it's super interesting because
there's something about covet and that
kind of thing too it's like because we
can then we will and we don't understand
that we don't calculate what that what
the causal effect is and what the cause
is like because we can lock everybody
down for two years pretty much and we
can force everybody to do this and do
that and force kids to wear masks and do
this we will we will do it because it
will work like we will we
we will let's say prevent
a certain amount of people from dying
from the disease and then not realizing
that it has a causal effect which is
beyond the disease yes yes it is
it's so often health you really have to
watch it so often health which is used
to to push these technologies so not you
know like even elon musk's neural link
i i don't know if what his first what
why what are you doing it but you say oh
it could be useful for people who are um
quadriplegic right
it's always health but it's also it's
interesting it actually gets back to the
children because it's often kind of like
thinking about thinking about the
children so people are persuaded of
digital id online because then you could
use that to make certain children can't
access pornography
for example that's one of the arguments
that used but also then like in terms of
covert but children were for collateral
damage they were
they were just used as shields for they
were used as shields for 85 year olds
so it's it it seems to be i mean i i
don't know if you got any thoughts about
that about what
there's something
is
something really what is it yeah what is
it what's going on what's happening uh
i think it's the i think we're i think
it really is the mcluhan's electric
beast like i think that what we're
seeing is
is
the possibilities of technology and the
possibilities of of
the possibilities of technologies are
advancing
through attention and through the past
just the capacity that it has and we are
just
we're just following
and so and it's not like nobody's
you hope most people are definitely not
doing it through ill means through ill
intent it's just
it's just happening it's like if a
possibility
of um
how can i say this it's like if i i can
impose a certain stricture and it'll and
it'll
i can do it through technical means then
it'll happen
and what it does is it makes that system
stronger and then it just keeps
happening over and over so there's no i
don't know like i don't have a solution
for it like i don't know exactly what
the
the like in terms of the idea of
sacrificing children to
to to the to the elderly um
i i do think that to a certain extent a
lot of what
the extent of the cobin measures that
were happening is like there's something
about a
there's something about the last moment
of the the boomer generation like the
last moment of the 60s and
um
some people get really angry that i say
that but i think that there's something
about it which is
which is there as well like a fear of
death like a fear of death that is
really pervasive and we don't know what
to do with it like we don't know how
to die and we don't know
we we so we we move from euthanasia to
these extreme measures and we don't know
how to manage
how to manage death
that's really interesting it's also
really interesting but like but
trying to advance you because you have
euthanasia in canada don't you yeah
yeah so
advancing euthanasia and trying to
extend life a kind of both for peace
it's a notion of control but one of the
things that really struck that really
struck me about how elderly people were
treated in britain and i'm sure it was
similar in canada was that they didn't
want them to die but they didn't want to
live either that's right they imprisoned
i know people that were imprisoned in
their apartment for months
basically could not leave could not walk
out on their porch had guards at the
door
and they were saying this is for your
protection and it's super interesting
because like there's a local restaurant
near my
like a little restaurant in my house and
as soon as the
the strictures would
would come down a little bit like they'd
be full of old people
and they'd be like oh don't they know
that they could get it don't they know
that they could die it's like stop
thinking they're idiots like people live
they want to live they don't want to
just be a living dead person for two
years you know getting imprisoned in
your
like they would show i remember if you
saw like they would show these these
crazy videos towards the end of some of
the measures where they would say a
husband and a wife you know that are
like 90 years old they haven't seen each
other in a year
yeah and they're like oh and now they're
celebrating because they're they're
seeing each other again what is
happening why didn't you just let them
see each other and maybe they would get
it and die but you risked like this this
you created this extreme pain between
these two people and you told them that
we're doing this for your own safety i
don't know that kind of stuff just drove
me nuts i was like what is happening
what is the story it's the same here
there were couples who were in the same
care home
the same care home but not allowed to
see each other and he's a and when
you're talking about somebody in the 80s
in their 80s or 90s that's not a boomer
generation they might have taken part in
the normandy landings liberated burgh
and belson
rescued people from fires and then oh
you can't go to your granddaughter's
wedding in case you catch a nasty
illness it's pathetic but for they're
not the boober generation but even the
boomer generation that is about a bit
ironic that these generations who kind
of like
uh took ludicrous amount of drugs and
rode around on motorbikes and and
now they're worried about dying now
but i think there's there is something
there is something in it about this this
this fear of fear of death
the fear of death and dust
yeah but that's what technology is
so so the technology is is ultimate like
technology primarily let's say
mythologically is to put off death
that's what it is right it's the
garments of skin it's the
it's the the it's the city of cain it's
the whole death at bay you know that's
what medicine is all of these things and
there's nothing wrong with that but we
can understand that
if we if we divorce technology from its
basic primal
reality which is a desire to stave off
death
through means that are taken from death
to a certain extent uh then we don't
understand it and then we will struggle
to understand why
and be surprised that people are
the transhumanists understand technology
as a way for immortal life that they
understand you know that it's all about
this this desire to
yeah to stave off death so as technical
society increases then
it's not
it's not surprising also that fear of
death increases as well
and this is not like it's not it's not a
it's not like it just it's not a weird
thing you know we experienced this when
we were in africa we experienced it so
much you know you
when you live with risk
uh you are less afraid
because you know that it can happen at
any time but you just live with risk so
we were living in congo we'd live in
local neighborhoods and so there was
always danger obviously but you would
you would manage the danger you would
you would live with it you would see it
but the people that lived in closed off
compounds completely closed off
compounds they're always scared
completely afraid to go out and couldn't
you know they would all of a sudden they
would look outside and everything was
danger and that's what that's also what
technology does as it makes you safer it
makes you more afraid there's no there's
no way around that and so
it's that's what we that's also what
we're seeing that's also what we've seen
for the last two years
yes so so that explains sort of like all
the anxiety about about safety on online
and thinking you have to have higher and
higher higher levels of security um
but so i think people think that
technology is increasing their agency
and it does increase it in certain ways
but it's decreasing it in other ways but
if you think of it if you think about it
in terms of
in terms of staving off fear of death
would that be a kind of
a way of making us see how it's
curtailing our agent our agency but
we're just willingly going along with it
but i think i think you said a little
while ago that we were just passively
going along with it but in a sense we're
not because we're sort of actively
actively colluding in our own
um fragmentation
which our notion of identity is being
coming fragment fragmented and ways in
which the technology is is often hacking
the worst bits of us
so you know in terms of like the online
the social media companies have worked
out that
but it's uh our worst um our worst
emotions are ones that are most easily
riled and the ones that are most
addictive like you know the ludicrous
you know the ludicrous righteous
indignation you can get in some having
some insane spat on twitter you don't
even know this person is yeah they're
maybe even anonymous like they don't
even know their name
yeah i know it's you're right but it has
to do with increased so there's also a
relationship with staving off death
and an increase in power
and so that's a real thing
right when you if you
if you stave off death and increase your
power it's like a drug obviously and
that increase in power
is
something that can happen at a very
physical level right which is that i
have a gun or i have a
fortified castle um but it can happen
also in terms of your influence and in
terms of your reputation because as i
increase in power and influence then i
the type of
feeling that i get from having a gun i
can also have from just
increasing my power of reputation and so
you can understand that so you can see
like if you can you can if you can
understand that it's related the notion
of
safety
increase in power
and but then it also leads to the
fragility at the same time all of these
things are happening are happening at
once uh and it's it's hard to kind of
capture analytically but you can to
capture it mythologically you can see
that there are many structures like that
where you see this this uh this this
image appear like one one of the the
biggest ones is the statue of daniel the
statue of nebuchadnezzar in the book of
daniel where you see this hierarchy of
metals and this soft metal at the top
and then these harder and harder metals
that are more powerful and more brittle
and then they end with
a kind of hybrid metal at the at the
bottom which is multiplicity which is
fragmentation which is quantity and then
but it's also the most fragile and then
the statue shatters so you can if you
think of like your
your online presence as something like
that also like the type of influence
that you have
with your wife or your husband
is something which is extremely
qualitative yes but is very limited
and then your family your your social
sphere your influence in your church or
whatever but then online
it's like the capacity you have to
influence and to to affect others is
huge but then it also has the other
characteristics of being fragmented and
fragile at the same time yeah so when
you yourself reflected back online is
fragmented and fragile so so one of the
one of the things i've been trying to
grapple with
and i haven't got
i'm not i'm still thinking about this
very programmatically is in terms of how
there's a paradox between how
the way we're using technology in the
online world is is kind of like really
prioritizing the self
as if the self and and not you know
yourself alone with a computer or a
smartphone is like the center of a world
and yet our notions of self are just
becoming increasingly fragmented and in
some in some of the sort of identities
that are coming up it's as if there's a
real priority to the mind or the self a
sort of like isolated little like almost
like a cartesian self or a cartesian
mind
as if that's got to take priority over
the body several ways you get so see
there seem to be so many body
modifications and
so many ways of it if you're if your
mind doesn't match your body you have to
change your body to we can the body is
just like a become a piece of technology
that we we can we can just use to alter
indicate you know the way in which hydra
to talk about the standing reserve of
the world yeah
your body's a standing reserve
your body's their own standing results
so you can put a chip in it to make it
easier to access everything if you want
you can you know you can you can change
sexes apparently you can you you can
have ludicrous piercings or you can just
present yourself in in different ways
but
i was actually thinking about i was
thinking about this in terms of how
descartes developed because people are
talking about is a dualism but how
descartes was thinking about this
because
nobody's a card cartesian dualist
anymore in the sense of descartes there
was a mental substance and a physical
substance nobody thinks there's a mental
substance and a physical substance but
then it kind of struck me but when when
i mean you probably know this but not
every people know it when descartes sat
down to write his discourse on the
method about how he came to the you know
he's came to his
conclusions that the crocodile were go
some i think therefore i am
um he'd done it at a time when the
reason why he was searching for
certainty because he was living at a
time with lots of different beliefs
around there was there was no certainty
as to what to believe
and he spent some time away just doing
things like spending years playing cards
with soldiers to try to wipe his mind
clean
and when he sat down to do this
he isolated himself he sat
alone in a stone heated room as he
described it i was thinking so
is that
solitude connected with the way which he
came to the conclusion that the
source of his certainty what he could
know for certain is his thinking cell
and
and so not just for substance but the
fact that this is the basis of his
epistemology yeah how similar that is
to the way in which people are walking
along
walking along not seeing the world
because they're on their phones or just
alone
with their computers is it do you think
i might have something to do with how
the mind is being prioritized and
i think i think you're right i think
that i think that it's a the way it's
always i when when when i think about
the contemporary word i always have to
think of it in extremes and so it's like
as we're presenting let's say as we're
presenting the extreme of the mind
um the isolated mind and this this this
idea of the mind looking at a screen and
tracking with the screen
there's there's also at the same time
a kind of
obsession with the
synchronies idiosyncrasy of the body as
well so you know in in a in a normal
world there would be less of both like
they would be less
they would be less obsessing with this
this kind of weird solipsistic world
where you self-define yourself and then
it would also be less obsessive with you
know
seeing that because there's also there's
also like a weird obsession with
gratification and the sense in which
the idiosyncrasies of the body also have
to be
met
yes and so that's kind of how that's
also the way it's presented if you pay
attention to some of the discourse it's
like the body wants this
what can i do that's what my body wants
like there's
there's like an extreme sense of
disjunction and that is so i see it more
as a disjunction and so so so
yes there's there is so but you can
already see it like in the time of
descartes and as as the as the um
as the enlightenment kind of
makes its way out is that you end up
having idealism and materialism and they
can't they can't bring them together
again and so we're seeing extreme
versions of that in individual lives
where people
are are on the one hand obsessed with
like
pleasure and obsessed with with side
with their their own like personal
idiosyncratic satisfaction but at the
same time they're divorced from their
body and they're living in this kind of
abstracted uh self-willing yes you know
solid cystic being so so that's the way
that i that i see that um
yeah that's the that's the way that i
kind of and there's also there's also a
weird thing that happens which is that
it seems like breaking down someone that
way um
seems to also make it possible for them
to get sucked into
[Music]
sucked into a night to suck into
something that will kind of
con
take them up let's say you know and so
give themselves to some some cause or
some identity that will completely uh
absorb them
you know and so that's why you you also
see these weird
neo-religious movements and these this
kind of near religious uh
politics you know and and you know the
clans and all of that it's like it's
it's all
it's it's because the clans are
important in the online space too so
it's not
it's as if doing this makes you also
like almost like uh
like um
like
something that was prone to being in a
cult or something like that i don't know
how else to say it
does that make sense yeah i think it
makes sense i said what so one of the
things there's lots of different things
happening at once i think so
one of the things that happening is is
distortion of time
so that every has got to be instant
so i mean even actually a friend was
saying the other day when she was a
she wanted to know why i hadn't got a
smartphone and she was saying oh but if
i'm out somewhere and i want to know
something i can find it out immediately
why do you want to know it immediately
even
there's a
is everything has got to be
really instant but also i think you'll
write about that point about just the
desire if you have there's a there's a
move around but if you have a desire for
something or even it's a fleeting desire
that's somehow part of your identity
yeah well you're getting about 8 000
trillion different kind of gender
identities and sexual orientations and
so on
because if you if you ever have some
sort of fleeting
desire then that must somehow reflect on
who you are which is
just but it's it's interesting because
it's it's not unrelated also to consumer
culture and to marketing and to like
mass capitalism because we have that
reality not just with our sexual desires
but we have that reality for everything
right you you want to eat something you
could probably find it whatever it is
whatever you can think of yes you know
if you're near any city you could
probably find what you want to eat you
go to the grocery store and you have
foods from everywhere in the entire
world that is there to you to available
to you and i can order something on
amazon and get it tomorrow and he pretty
much almost and if i can't i'm annoyed
it's like wait what why isn't there two
days shipping for this one thing i have
to wait two weeks really like it just
gets it gets on your nerves and so so
it's like this instant gratification is
is all over the place yeah it's not just
yeah but i mean that that also links
back to what we were talking about at
the beginning about agency
about building up a skill and building
up a character over a long period of
time but this is just the reverse of
that this is the idea that you've got to
form what your identity is i bet maybe
that's one of the reasons why people's
identities are shifting
shifting so much but somebody can say
you know some celebrities can come out
one week they're non-binary the next
week make weak bed trans then
but but that's kind of a reverse of the
idea that you'll build you're building
up something which is can get integrated
into yourself over a long period of time
but it's got to be
all done at times which is gone yeah
well i mean i think it's all there is
definitely an inversion that happened in
general like and then it happened really
in the 1960s most most basically where
it really was that there was a sense in
which
we shifted we twist we inverted it we
said that your identities
are socially constructed
and therefore they have no validity
they're not real they're just social
construction your desires because
they're experienced
then those are real and those are that
on which you should base your identity
and it's really opposite of any
traditional world like any any
traditional religion or any traditional
world where there's a sense in which you
participate in these in these identities
that are
that come from above you could say
and those are the ones that are the most
stable but those down here like these
little desires they're constantly
shifting they're always changing you
know they then you can have
contradictory desires you can have
desires that you can hate someone and
love them at the same time and so you
actually have to be careful with down
here with all these desires because
they'll lead you into
chaos and confusion and tyranny and and
so it's like all these things are going
to happen but i mean that's a that's a
basic major change that happened in in
the in the past few generations that had
been kind of building up i think from
materialism itself yes you can
understand that that's that's one of the
implications of materialism is that
identity comes from below it comes from
this this stuff not from
not from these these structures that are
that are come from above those are just
tyrannies they're just
you know methods of of controlling
others and all that stuff so
the the trouble is very deep like in
terms of of how to how to to
if if we can't get out of that thinking
already like we're we're
going to be we're going to be in trouble
no matter what because if you if you
really think that your desires are
have are real and that you should be led
by them
after that no matter what no matter what
you're you're always going to
you're always going to be turning in a
in a circle in a wheel
yes so yeah so it's so it may it
you it may well be that like from the
60s that that came into popular culture
but it's actually been present in
philosophy for longer than that
so but you could see it in
utilitarianism
from the idea that what we need to do is
so jeremy bentham's talked about how
mankind is um under two sovereign
masters so for motivation to to seek
happiness or to avoid pain
so you can always see you can always see
some point of that because of course
it's more it's stronger in terms of pain
because it's
if you're using that as a basis for that
but basis for ethics it might not be
enough as total basis but you can see
the attraction of thinking but of course
i mean inflicting gratuitous pain must
be i must be must be wrong
and and then more modern versions of
utilitarianism are actually desire based
so thinking that because there are
problems with
we don't just want to have the
experience of happiness we want to
actually do we want to actually do stuff
you know
don nozix i didn't have john knows it i
never remember
the philosopher nozick i can't remember
his first name
he invented the idea of the experience
machine yeah
but you could just go in and just have
all these experiences but nothing real
was happening you know like yeah i know
and i i also read recently that they
they they tried to read ask some
students about this again like they
tried to redo the experience and that
the results were radically different
than what they were when he came up with
the experiment but more students wanted
to go in yeah
like a lot more a lot more people wanted
to go in now oh right yeah because
because because i because i always ask
i've always i've taught this for years
i've always asked the students about it
and it's always a substantial minority
of students who say bitcoin mostly men
actually mostly boys
but so but but from the idea that what
we want to do is have our desires
satisfied
and you can see how that might be a
preference you know move on from that
but then there are all sorts of ways in
which you might try to solve a problem
that desires can be fleeting so harry
frankfurt brought in an idea about
higher order or lower order desires but
we can order them in some way but you
haven't you might have a desire not to
have a certain desire so you might
require not to
pig out
last thing at night for example but that
but that still has but still has a
problem there's no there's no
nothing outside the
field of desires you just have to get
into a coherent system but this is this
this is actually i mean this actually
comes into a lot of the computing and a
lot of work in ai
so um so for example
stuart russell have you ever come across
his work
he's he's like a leading ai type he's
co-written but what's probably the
um
most well-used textbook on ai
and he's also recently two or three
years ago written a book
about super intelligence
he's trying to answer them trying to
address nick bostrom who wrote a book on
super intelligence
about while ago now about six years ago
i think
was worried about looking at the problem
about how super intelligence might
develop in a way that's going to control
us
how can we stop how can we build ai in a
way that's going to make certain but
it's going to align with human values so
but stuart russell is trying to do a
second go at trying to refine that but
his way of doing it is to say
because his definition of intelligence
which is widely used is completely
instrumental
so intelligence is judged in terms of
how well or how efficiently you reach a
goal
so the goals aren't part of the
definition of intelligence it could be
any goal
so you could intelligently kill the
whole human race for example
talk to people so the goal's got to be
put in there so the question is how do
we stop
insofar as super intelligence is
possible which is another another
question how can we make certain that
it's aligned with our goals so russell's
idea in a nutshell is to train
the ai
to observe our desires and our behavior
and extrapolate oh my god extrapolate
yeah that's what i thought yeah
extrapolate extrapolate from how we how
we're behaving so that it can know
what it can learn what humans really
want yeah that's great yeah especially
if you do that online that's super duper
there
that's not going to end well
yeah so somebody if it's going to
extrapolate from human behavior how
could it extrapolate when it hasn't got
it hasn't got that shared experience of
a human being in the same way like you
know my friend instantly we both
instantly knew we were trying to catch
that
cat from the person who stole my purse
yeah and also if you can't tell the
difference between quantitative and
qualitative realities which is that you
know
you might get married just once in your
life
but that thing might be the most
important of your the most important
thing that you're aspiring to but every
day i do stupid things and i play video
games and i whatever and and do things
that are boring and useless but if you
ask me what's the most important i'll
still tell you that it's the one thing
that happened that one time and so the
idea that you could extrapolate out of
human desires is hilarious because most
of the time our desires are pointless
well that point is but they they they
really are based and they kind of lead
us into base behaviors yeah yeah i know
actually so if you'd ask me a question
about you know which two days of my life
were i happiest there were also for two
days when i had the most pain because
that's when i had my kids right
how could you extrapolate
from that exactly no you i think you
you've got it right but it's interesting
like
maybe i want to finish with one last
point which which maybe you can can uh i
want to get your opinion on because it
it actually comes down to what we talked
about a little bit at the outset in
terms of the idea the question of
understanding agency or even
consciousness of higher order beings
as being
framed in human
in in humanity that is that the
hierarchy of beings itself
is the actual
frame by which consciousness and
intelligence happens right so it happens
through agents it's not something that
happens just up there in the sphere
right and so the agency and the
consciousness of a group culminates into
leaders into
you know into to to beings that actually
have a position right so i think that
that's one of the things that people
seem to
i think
maybe some people are thinking about it
but in terms of super intelligence or in
terms of artificial intelligence and the
idea of
the idea of the the you know the that
intelli that ai could surpass us right i
think that
we need to always understand it within
the human
hierarchy which is that intelligence
will be
it depends who is going to wield it and
those in power will always wield it and
so artificial intelligence will all just
always be more power
and it will be wielded by those that
already have power and so the i and so
whether or not the the computer is
thinking on its own or whether or not it
is fully conscious or whatever you'll
never know that you can never verify
that you'll never be able to have that
experience but what you can see is you
can see the fingers of those that
the kings and the powerful in the world
of how they will they will utilize that
power to for for certain actual purposes
and so i think that we should not be
naive like the idea that you could
program
good intentions in ai it's like who's
going to be wielding that ai who's going
to hold it who's going to hold the reins
who's going to hold the on off switch
who's going to like who's going to
decide what information gets put into it
all of that is what's most more
important than the actual
algorithms themselves like although they
can be super powerful and and that
that that's the real question is is
that's more important than than the
other questions in my opinion
yeah i think you're right because in a
way where
there's a real tendency to think of ai
as if it's a separate agency when ai is
just something that's produced by people
and used by people so like the control
problem in ai is is it is a problem it
is an issue in the technology but to
make certain it does what you want it to
do which is a problem because it's a
problem with like with any computer
program you could write a computer
program in it everybody who writes
programs know that they don't always
work it's just and because it's so
complex there's there's
there's a big problem with that
but it's it's for people
i mean i think the real control problem
is the people who are using the ai the
people who've got all the power the big
companies
i mean i mean look what's happening in
our world this is
this is not so much a matter of ar but
the day that we're recording this and
waiting to find out whether elon musk is
going to buy twitter
so i sometimes think that's one of the
reasons why the state wants to control
individuals because they've given up
the
the the
any idea that they could control all
these billionaire tech people who are
ones who are really running the world so
it's so it's yeah i think you're right
it is but we tend to attribute agency to
something
we tend to attribute cause to whatever
seems to be new or distinctive if
there's a complex situation you'll pick
out the person who looks a bit different
or the new thing that's just happened
but that's often a mistake that's what's
happening with with with tech the ai is
made by people it's operated by people a
lot yeah
and you know
you're right on both like if you look at
the you know my situation it's it's
really interesting because you can
actually see how everybody knows that
implicitly like everybody really knows
that implicitly because you have people
that are
in this situation where must might buy
twitter you have people that are
cheering and are gloating and are so
excited because they align themselves
with elon musk and his way of thinking
and what he's doing and then you have
people that are freaking out and are
completely losing their mind
um
and the thing is is that
so for example so this is also the
problem so like for example twitter
couldn't the idea that let's say elon
musk will bring back free speech to
twitter like just frame it that way
elon musk is not going to bring back
absolute free speech to twitter that's
not going to happen because you just the
fact that you have to create hierarchies
in the manner in which information is
displayed means that whatever you think
free speech is it can't it can't
completely exist
because you have to prioritize you can't
get the flood of all twitter
at once in your face it's not it's not
it's not possible that that happens so
there has to be a kind of prioritization
and therefore that prioritization is
based on a hierarchy of values and that
hierarchy of values will appear in the
way in which information is displayed to
you so
i mean i can understand why people are
i mean i'm annoyed at twitter because i
don't like their their hierarchy the way
that they they create hierarchy
of values i think it's lopsided i think
that it's only it's only on one
political in one political direction and
so i'm annoyed and i find it frustrating
but but people who think that
all that's going to happen is like your
opening of free speech
that's not how it works information
doesn't work that way yes it's also not
going to work because in different
countries you can you can i mean like in
britain lots of people have been
you know interviewed by the police for
example over what they said on twitter
or lost a bit i've actually lost their
jobs over stuff they said on twitter wow
so so yeah
so
there's a well-known case here of a
woman
maybe she didn't say on twitter but
there's most cases of people who've who
get into trouble for for saying really
outrageous things like
men can't be women
yeah well that's what i mean it shows
you that
yeah but it's revealing how it's
definitely revealing
it's revealing where the principalities
are when that happens like you can see
if you wanna you can actually detect
who's in charge like who's running the
story who's playing the show yeah it's
also interesting about a lot of the
newspapers and media
outlets that are coming out outraged
about musk advice
the washington post owned by jeff bezos
but you know
it's so funny i mean that for sure is
hilarious like
yeah i have to admit that i've been i've
been perversely enjoying the whole thing
like it just i just find it hilarious
and it's making me want to pull away
from twitter even more but it's still
funny to watch to watch that people
become very obvious like like things
become very obvious in the in these
types of moments
we've been going for a while and i need
to i need to go but this is this was
wonderful as usual we need to plan like
every once in a while come back and
continue our discussion that would be
great i've really enjoyed it and it was
yeah it was it's interesting how the
different ideas um
between agency and ideal all match up
yeah in the end even though we didn't
know we were going to bring them
together they turned out that they
sorry i couldn't i'm sorry i couldn't
remember what i'd written you this email
about agency and i couldn't remember
what i'd said but yeah
i like my lack of agency but it's been
great talking to you it's really
interesting and fun as well
thanks for thanks for your time and uh
and for people who were listening the
opening of this video
uh the the music it's like that we're
gonna put in the heavy metal version
which was done by
uh my nephew jamie yeah
and so and so paula is the one who who
who i think you reached out to your
nephew and said oh would you like to do
a version of this and they did this
great heavy metal version that a lot of
people love people really love it so so
dad thanks here thank you thank your
nephew jamie for us we really enjoy it
yes i will yeah yeah
all right everybody thanks for attention
and we'll see you soon
as you know the symbolic world is not
just a bunch of videos on youtube we are
also a podcast which you can find on
your uh usual podcast platform but we
also have a website with a blog and
several very interesting articles by
very intelligent people that have been
thinking about symbolism on all kinds of
subjects we also have a clips channel a
facebook group you know there's a whole
lot of ways that you can get more
involved in the exploration and the
discussion of symbolism don't forget
that my brother matsuya wrote a book
called the language of creation which is
a very powerful synthesis of a lot of
the ideas that explore and so please go
ahead and explore this world you can
also participate by you know buying
things that i've designed t-shirts with
different designs on them and you can
also support this podcast and these
videos through paypal or through patreon
everybody who supports me has access to
an extra video a month and there are
also all kinds of other goodies and
tiers that you can get involved with so
everybody thank you again and thank you
for your support